A couple weeks ago, I heard this show on the radio where they were trying to explain why most people in most elections prefer Republicans these days. And there was a writer named Thomas Frank on the show, going around with this book that he just published about politics in Kansas. He is interested in why Kansans would keep voting for Republicans at every level, even though Republican economic policies and social policies weren't doing much to help them. And, he says, they actually made their lives tougher in a lot of ways. Hurt farmers. Hurt the Kansas economy. The poorest county in the country went for President Bush with an 80% majority in the last election.
几周前，我在广播里听到一个节目，试图解释为什么如今大多数选民在大多数选举中更倾向于支持共和党。节目请来了一位名叫托马斯·弗兰克的作家，他带着刚出版的关于堪萨斯州政治的书四处宣传。他很感兴趣，为什么堪萨斯人会一直在各个层级投票给共和党，尽管共和党的经济政策和社会政策并没有给他们带来多少帮助。他说，这些政策在很多方面实际上让他们的生活变得更艰难了。伤害了农民，伤害了堪萨斯州的经济。在上次选举中，全国最贫困的县以80%的多数票支持了布什总统。
Frank's argument-- you may have heard him talk about this on that book tour-- is that Republicans were getting people to vote against their own economic self-interest by appealing to their values on cultural issues, on abortion, on God. Though as Frank and the other guest on this radio show, On Point, said-- the other guest was Atlantic Monthly senior editor, Jack Beatty-- the Democrats haven't been very good for most Kansans' economic interests either.
弗兰克的观点——你们可能在那个新书巡回宣传中听他谈过——是共和党通过诉诸文化议题、堕胎、上帝等价值观，诱使人们违背自己的经济利益去投票。尽管正如弗兰克和广播节目《On Point》的另一位嘉宾——《大西洋月刊》高级编辑杰克·比蒂——所言，民主党在堪萨斯人的经济利益方面也做得不怎么样。
You know, it's hard to say that the people voting for the Republican party are all that wrong. I mean, neither party represents their interests. So they vote for the party that better represents their values. And that is the GOP.
你知道，很难说投票给共和党的人都错了。我的意思是，两个党都没能代表他们的利益。所以他们投票给更能代表他们价值观的政党。而那就是共和党。
Exactly.
确实如此。
It delivers. Gag rule on abortion internationally, stem cell research, abstinence-only programs in the schools, an effort to appoint anti-choice judges. It delivers, or tries to deliver, on the values agenda. Whereas the Democrats-- I mean, look at Clinton. He gave the Midwest NAFTA, the China health deal. They didn't get health care.
它兑现了。国际上的堕胎禁令、干细胞研究、学校里的禁欲教育计划、任命反堕胎法官的努力。它实现了，或者说试图实现其价值观议程。而民主党——我的意思是，看看克林顿。他给中西部带来了《北美自由贸易协定》和对华贸易协定。他们却没得到医疗保障。
So it's hard to turn around to the people who've lost their livelihoods and say, vote for us. We're the party that will-- well, what will we do? Well, we'll expose you to international competition. Whereas the Republicans are going to do the same thing. But at least they're going to make noises on the culture war.
所以，对那些失去生计的人说“投给我们吧”很难。我们是那个将要……好吧，我们要怎么做？我们要让你们面对国际竞争。而共和党也会做同样的事情。但至少他们会在文化战争上制造声势。
Soon they got to callers. The first was this Republican voter who said that of course he wasn't just voting his pocketbook. That would be crude.
很快他们转到了听众电话环节。第一位是共和党选民，他说他当然不只是为了自己的钱包投票。那太低级了。
Your commentator's points about their voting against their economic best interests, well there's more of concern to me than who's going to give me a tax break, or who's going to build a factory in my town. I've got a lot of other interests that are important to me.
你们评论员关于他们违背经济利益去投票的观点，对我来说，这比谁会给我减税，或者谁会到我的城镇建工厂更重要。我还有许多其他对我来说很重要的利益。
This caller said that he disagreed with the Republicans on a bunch of things. But he said that one nice thing about the Republican Party is that it welcomes people who disagree with them on this particular issue, or that particular issue. Whereas, he said, Democrats, if you're pro-life, it doesn't feel like there's any place for you in the party. The next caller said the same thing, that there was no room in the Democratic Party for a diversity of views.
这位打来电话的人说，他在很多问题上不同意共和党的观点。但他表示，共和党的一大优点是，它欢迎在某个特定议题上与他们意见不同的人。相比之下，他说，民主党人，如果你是反堕胎人士，感觉党内就没有你的立足之地。下一位听众也说了同样的话，认为民主党内没有多元观点的空间。
If you even contemplate, if you even advocate even restrictions on abortion-- which even the majority of people of the United States would favor-- there's no room for you in the Democratic Party. You won't be allowed to speak at the Convention to advocate the idea that the state should decide when and under what circumstances abortion should be allowed.
如果你哪怕只是思考、哪怕只是主张对堕胎进行限制——甚至大多数美国人都赞同这一点——民主党内就没有你的位置。你将不被允许在代表大会上发言，以主张国家应该决定在何时以及何种情况下允许堕胎。
Of course, famously, in 1992, Pennsylvania's Democratic governor, Robert Casey, wasn't allowed to speak at his own party's convention, because he was pro-life. Republicans control the House, they control the Senate, they control the White House. They have 28 of 50 governorships. They control the House and the Senate in 21 State Houses. Seven out of nine Supreme Court Justices are Republican appointees. And they dominate the majority of federal appellate courts, as well.
当然，众所周知，1992年，宾夕法尼亚州的民主党州长罗伯特·凯西就不被允许在本党代表大会上发言，因为他是反堕胎的。共和党控制了众议院，控制了参议院，控制了白宫。他们在50个州里拥有28个州长席位。他们在21个州的州议会中控制了众议院和参议院。九名最高法院大法官中有七名是共和党任命的。他们也主导了大多数联邦上诉法院。
They are on the march. Republicans are positioning themselves as America's majority party. And what that means is-- though Democrats may find this surprising, given the fact that blacks, and Jews, and Hispanics still vote mostly for Democrats-- lots of people find the Republican Party to be more inclusive, more welcoming, more accepting of diverging views.
他们正在前进。共和党人正将自己定位为美国的多数党。这意味着——尽管民主党人可能会感到惊讶，鉴于黑人、犹太人和西班牙裔仍然主要投票给民主党——许多人发现共和党更具包容性，更欢迎、更接受不同的观点。
This is what Newt Gingrich was talking about, just last week, when he declared that yes, there is a party of narrow-minded bigotry in this country. It's called the Democrats. He meant that the Democrats are the ones who demand that you fall into lockstep on abortion, and affirmative action, and all sorts of other political correctness besides.
这就是纽特·金里奇就在上周所谈论的内容，当时他宣称，是的，这个国家确实存在一个狭隘偏执的党派。它叫民主党。他的意思是，民主党人正是那些要求你在堕胎、平权行动以及除此之外所有政治正确问题上步调一致的人。
Today on our radio show, Republicans on the March. Their party is great at getting elected. And they do it very smartly, by papering over the differences come election time. On today's program, though, we leave aside the official talking points that Republicans are saying everywhere until November, and ask Republicans to speak instead about what they actually believe, and what they want for their party, and for the country. And it's way more complicated than you might think. Not just Christians on the one side of the Party fighting with moderates on the other. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our radio show, Republicans, The Party of Inclusion.
今天我们的广播节目主题是“前进中的共和党”。他们的党派非常擅长赢得选举。而且他们做得非常精明，在选举时掩盖分歧。不过，在今天的节目中，我们抛开共和党人在11月前到处宣扬的官方口径，转而请共和党人谈谈他们真正相信什么，以及他们希望为自己的党派和国家做什么。这比你想象的要复杂得多。不仅仅是党内一侧的基督徒与另一侧的温和派在斗争。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《这美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的广播节目是：共和党，包容的政党。
Act One of our program, Pink Elephant. In that act, a Republican on what might seem like an ill-fated mission to win the hearts and minds of his fellow Republicans at their convention. Act Two, Right and Righter. A visit to one of the many states where the Republican Party has been picking up strength. To see how and why, we spend some time with the Alabama Republican Party.
我们节目的第一幕，“粉红大象”。在这一幕中，一位共和党人执行了一项看起来注定失败的任务，试图在共和党大会上赢得共和党同僚的心。第二幕，“更右与最右”。走访共和党势力不断增强的众多州之一。为了看看是如何以及为什么发生的，我们花时间与阿拉巴马州共和党人在一起。
Act Three, Indecent Proposal. In that act, free market Republicans in this story, about a rich guy who knows that every person has his price. And so he goes to his Republican co-workers with an offer of money-- lots and lots of money-- if they will dare to spend just one evening with him, doing an act that most Republicans would find utterly repulsive, namely watching the Michael Moore film.
第三幕，“不雅提议”。在这一幕中，自由市场的共和党人出现在这个故事里，关于一个富人知道每个人都有价码。于是他向他的共和党同事提议，如果他们敢和他共度一个晚上，做一件大多数共和党人会觉得极其反感的事情，即观看迈克尔·摩尔的电影，就给他们一大笔钱。
Act Four, It's My Party. One of the most civil conversations that you will ever hear between one side of the Party, that feels like it should be included, and the other, that feels that maybe it should not. Stay with us.
第四幕，“这是我的派对”。你所能听到的关于党内感到应该被包容的一方，与认为可能不应该被包容的另一方之间，最文明的对话之一。留下来。
Act One, Pink Elephant. Patrick Howell came to the Republican Convention this year on a mission that makes you wonder if he's in denial about the state of today's Republican Party, or if he knows a lot more about it than you do.
第一幕，“粉红大象”。帕特里克·豪威尔今年来到共和党大会，带着一项任务，让你怀疑他是对当今共和党的状态处于否认中，还是他比你了解得更多。
I saw it as a great opportunity to bring the inclusive Log Cabin message to the delegates that I happened to meet.
我认为这是一个绝佳的机会，可以向我碰巧遇到的代表们传达包容性的“原木小屋”信息。
The Log Cabin message is the message of gay Republicans. Log Cabin, you may already know, is the name of the gay Republicans' official national organization. And their inclusive message definitely had an uphill battle at this year's convention. Not only did the party adopt a platform calling for a constitutional amendment to outlaw gay marriage, and decrying that homosexuality is not compatible with military service, gay Republicans couldn't even talk a single delegate into presenting their side of things for discussion at the platform committee. They were totally shut out. Nationally, just 11% of Republican voters support same-sex marriage. Hence Patrick's plan.
“原木小屋”信息是同性恋共和党人的信息。“原木小屋”是你可能已经知道的同性恋共和党人正式全国组织的名称。他们的包容性信息在今年的大会上确实遭遇了严峻挑战。该党不仅采纳了一项要求通过宪法修正案取缔同性婚姻的纲领，并声称同性恋与军队服役不兼容，同性恋共和党人甚至无法说服哪怕一名代表在纲领委员会上提出他们的一方进行讨论。他们被完全排斥在外。在全国范围内，只有11%的共和党选民支持同性婚姻。因此有了帕特里克的计划。
I get to go to all the breakfasts, and all of the events, and get onto the convention floor.
我可以参加所有的早餐会、所有的活动，并进入大会会场。
And so, what does that mean? What do you think you're going to be doing?
那么，这意味着什么？你觉得你要做什么？
Well, really just showing them that there are gay Republicans out there, that there needs to be a big tent approach, in order to win over the broader public, the suburban voters that are much more moderate.
好吧，其实就是向他们展示有同性恋共和党人的存在，为了赢得更广泛的公众、那些温和得多的郊区选民，需要一种大帐篷的策略。
In his experience talking to Republicans, which is considerable, this is the most effective sell, that tolerance wins elections. 1.1 million gays and lesbians voted for President Bush in the year 2000, just a fourth of the gay vote overall, but enough to make a difference for the president. In Florida, that works out to nearly 50,000 votes, the Log Cabin Republicans say.
根据他与共和党人交谈的经验（他经验丰富），最有效的推销方式是：宽容赢得选举。在2000年，有110万同性恋者投票给布什总统，虽然只占同性恋选票总数的四分之一，但足以对总统产生影响。“原木小屋”共和党人表示，在佛罗里达州，这相当于近5万张选票。
Patrick is in his 30s, an attorney in Orlando. Until a few years ago he was married. He has a little boy from that marriage. Then he came out. He has always been a Republican, and agrees with the president on pretty much everything, he says, except gay issues. The treatment that he gets in his own party has varied quite a bit. For instance, county Republican leaders specifically reached out and invited Patrick to run for the state assembly two years ago, in a district in Orlando that's mostly Democrats and gay-friendly. The State Party gave him the maximum, $50,000, and hooked him up with another $50,000 in third party ads. But then the Republican who used to hold that seat actually endorsed Patrick's Democratic opponent in the race, rather than support a gay candidate. Patrick has gotten some nasty emails, saying, why don't you leave the party? You're not wanted. But the nastiness, he says, happens less often than you'd think. One-on-one, he finds most Republicans are glad to sit down and talk to him.
帕特里克30多岁，是奥兰多的律师。直到几年前他还有过一段婚姻。他和那段婚姻有一个小男孩。后来他出柜了。他说他一直是个共和党人，除了同性恋议题外，他在几乎所有事情上都支持总统。他在自己党内受到的待遇差异很大。例如，两年前，县共和党领导人曾专门联系并邀请帕特里克竞选州议员，选区在奥兰多，那里主要是民主党人和同性恋友好人士。州党部给了他5万美元上限的资金，并为他配套了另外5万美元的第三方广告。但后来，曾担任该席位的共和党人却支持了帕特里克的民主党对手，而不是支持一名同性恋候选人。帕特里克收到过一些恶毒的电子邮件，说“你为什么不离开这个党？这里不欢迎你”。但他表示，这种恶意行为比你想象的要少得多。一对一的时候，他发现大多数共和党人都很乐意坐下来和他谈谈。
You know, people that just know you on the fringe, but then you end up sitting at a voter registration booth with them for four hours on a Saturday. And suddenly that person leaves really knowing everything about me.
你知道，那些只在边缘认识你的人，但后来你会在周六和他们在选民登记处坐上四个小时。突然之间，那个人离开时真的对我的所有情况了如指掌。
And Patrick, what do you find in that kind of situation, that tends to change people's mind?
那么帕特里克，在这种情况下，你发现什么倾向于改变人们的想法？
I think that it's just the realization that I'm not that different from themselves.
我认为这只是意识到我其实和他们并没有什么不同。
And so, basically, you talk about your kid. You talk about going to church.
所以，基本上，你谈论你的孩子。你谈论去教堂。
Right. Right.
没错。没错。
During this extraordinary and even challenging moment, we have discovered who our friends are. And with us today, our friend and yours, Mayor Michael Bloomberg.
在这个非凡甚至充满挑战的时刻，我们发现了谁是我们的朋友。今天和我们在一起的，是我们的朋友，也是你们的朋友，迈克尔·布隆伯格市长。
In New York, the first Republican Convention event that Patrick attended was run by his own organization, the Log Cabin Republicans. In the wake of their defeats at the Platform Committee, they staged what they called the Big Tent Event, with as many high-profile mainstream politicians as they could sign up. The very liberal-minded Republican Mayor of New York, Michael Bloomberg, kicked things off to a room with a few hundred people in it, which for gay Republicans, is a huge turnout.
在纽约，帕特里克参加的第一场共和党大会活动是由他自己的组织“原木小屋”共和党人举办的。在纲领委员会遭遇失败后，他们举办了所谓的“大帐篷活动”，尽可能多地邀请了知名主流政客。纽约市非常自由派的共和党市长迈克尔·布隆伯格在一个有几百人的房间里拉开了序幕，这对同性恋共和党人来说是一个巨大的出席人数。
As the host of this reception, I want to tell you that a few years ago, I used this event as an occasion to come out, as a Republican, you should know.
作为这次招待会的主持人，我想告诉你们，几年前，我利用这个活动作为契机出柜，作为一个共和党人，你们应该知道。
The mayor talked about inclusiveness being the future of the Party, and about how constitutional amendments shouldn't be used to divide people. New York governor Pataki, who is such a rising star in the party, that he was the one who introduced President Bush at the convention later in the week, who is a possible 2008 presidential contender himself, felt enough solidarity with the gay Republicans to show up at this event, but not enough solidarity to actually mention in his remarks inclusiveness, the place of gays in the party, the place of moderates in the party, gay marriage, homosexuals, or really any other Log Cabin issues at all. It was the sort of speech he could have given to any group of Republicans.
市长谈到了包容性是党的未来，以及宪法修正案不应该被用来分裂人们。纽约州州长帕塔基是党内冉冉升起的新星，他甚至在周晚些时候在大会上介绍了布什总统，他本人也是2008年总统竞选的潜在人选，他感到与同性恋共和党人的团结足以让他出席这场活动，但团结程度还不足以在讲话中真正提及包容性、同性恋在党内的位置、温和派在党内的位置、同性婚姻、同性恋者，或者任何其他“原木小屋”议题。这是一种他本可以向任何共和党团体发表的演讲。
We are going to have a great week here in New York. And we are going to have a celebration of the greatest city in the world. And at the end of that week, I hope you leave with a little more-- Wait, I didn't mean it that way.
我们要在这里度过美好的一周。我们要庆祝世界上最伟大的城市。在那一周结束时，我希望你们带走多一点……等等，我不是那个意思。
The surprise stars of the day were Arlen Specter and William Weld. Senator Specter, a Republican from Pennsylvania, said that he didn't know, and he didn't care, if supporting gay rights would help Republicans win elections. These are fundamental rights, he said.
当天的惊喜明星是阿伦·斯佩克特和威廉·韦尔德。来自宾夕法尼亚州的共和党参议员斯佩克特说，他不知道，也不在乎支持同性恋权利是否会帮助共和党赢得选举。他说，这些是基本权利。
Then came William Weld, former governor of Massachusetts, another possible presidential candidate for 2008. If you've heard President Bush rail against activist judges legalizing marriage, Governor Weld would remind you that some of those judges are Republican appointees, including the head of the Massachusetts Supreme Court, who he appointed, and who legalized gay marriage in that state. Weld talked about his gay and lesbian friends, about gay and lesbian members of his own administration in Massachusetts.
接着是前马萨诸塞州州长威廉·韦尔德，他是2008年总统竞选的另一位潜在人选。如果你听过布什总统抨击激进法官合法化婚姻，韦尔德州长会提醒你，其中一些法官是共和党任命的，包括他任命的马萨诸塞州最高法院院长，正是该法官在该州使同性婚姻合法化。韦尔德谈到了他的同性恋朋友，以及他自己在马萨诸塞州政府中的同性恋成员。
As a matter of fact, it was my pleasure to return to Massachusetts in June of this year to marry my former chief of staff, Kevin Smith, and a former cabinet member, Mitchell Adams.
事实上，我很高兴能在今年6月回到马萨诸塞州，为我的前幕僚长凯文·史密斯和前内阁成员米切尔·亚当斯主持婚礼。
And from there, the Republican Weld laid out a position on gay marriage that is far more liberal than the supposedly super liberal John Kerry's position. Kerry opposes gay marriage.
从那里开始，共和党人韦尔德提出了一个在同性婚姻问题上的立场，比所谓的超级自由派约翰·克里的立场要自由得多。克里反对同性婚姻。
Let me just say one word about the federal constitutional amendment on gay marriage. You know, I've been invited to oppose this amendment on states' rights grounds, on the ground that this should be left to the states. And I've jumped over that issue. I prefer to oppose this amendment on substantive grounds, on the merit. It's the conservative point of view. It's making the same demands on gays and lesbians that are made on everyone else when they want to commit to each other. To me, it's kind of obvious. And the fact that some people have gay and lesbian preferences is not something that's going to be changed based on what somebody in the legislature says. And I don't know whether the percentage of the population is 10%, or 5%, or 15%, or 1%. It doesn't matter. You're not going to repeal biology in the United States Senate or the House, no matter what you do.
关于联邦宪法同性婚姻修正案，我只想说一句话。你知道，我曾被邀请以州权为由反对这一修正案，理由是这应该留给各州。而我跳过了那个议题。我更倾向于在实质性基础上，基于功过反对这一修正案。这是保守派的观点。它对同性恋者提出的要求，与对其他人想要彼此承诺时所提出的要求是一样的。对我来说，这显而易见。有些人有同性恋倾向，这不是某人在立法机构说了什么就能改变的。我不知道人口比例是10%，还是5%，或是15%，还是1%。这不重要。你不能在美国参议院或众议院废除生物学，无论你怎么做。
Patrick was one of the people clapping enthusiastically when Weld said that, and when Arlen Specter talked about gay rights being a matter of principle.
当韦尔德那样说时，当阿伦·斯佩克特谈到同性恋权利是原则问题时，帕特里克是热烈鼓掌的人之一。
I love that. It was just nice to be able to hear it articulated by someone that has a national presence.
我喜欢那样。能听到一个有全国影响力的人这样表达出来真是太好了。
Yeah, when he said that, again, I was just like, wow, I don't know if I've ever heard anyone say that, Democrat or Republican.
是啊，他那样说的时候，我又是觉得，哇，我不知道是否听过任何人这样说，无论是民主党还是共和党。
I don't think I have either. And it's wonderful to hear. I've never heard that.
我想我也没听过。听到这个真是太棒了。我从没听过。
You've never heard that.
你从没听过。
No. It's totally amazing. I mean that's not even the message that we send. We send the message that hey, this is the thing that's going to increase our party numbers. And it's the thing that's going to make our party the majority party. We try to appeal to the brain, as opposed to the heart. But I don't know. Maybe we need to start appealing to both.
没有。这真是太令人惊奇了。我的意思是，这甚至不是我们传达的信息。我们传达的信息是，嘿，这是增加我们党内人数的事情。这是使我们政党成为多数党的事情。我们试图诉诸大脑，而不是心灵。但我不知道。也许我们需要开始两者兼顾。
Hey, how are you?
嘿，你好吗？
Hello.
你好。
At the convention one night, at Madison Square Garden, I hovered around Patrick as he walked up to seven different groups of Republicans, wearing his Log Cabin inclusion pin. A lady from Texas in a red cowboy hat and red boots and a handsome couple from Virginia both pretty much iced Patrick when the subject of gay marriage came up, which Patrick took as opposition to gay marriage. A young African American guy was for gay marriage, as were two rich people from Miami. One of them turned out to be gay. And the other, his friend, turned out to be a big Republican donor, on the chairman's advisory board. Three other people that Patrick approached fell into kind of a gray area, against gay marriage, but in ways that gave him some kind of sliver of hope. There was this family from Utah, who seemed open to the idea of civil unions. And there was this Korean War vet.
在麦迪逊广场花园的大会期间，我徘徊在帕特里克身边，看着他戴着“原木小屋”包容徽章，走向七个不同的共和党小组。一位戴着红色牛仔帽和红靴子的德州女士，以及一对来自弗吉尼亚州的英俊夫妇，当谈到同性婚姻时，基本上都冷落了帕特里克，帕特里克将其视为对同性婚姻的反对。一位年轻的非裔美国人支持同性婚姻，来自迈阿密的一对富人也是如此。其中一个人原来是同性恋。而他的朋友，原来是一位共和党大金主，在主席咨询委员会任职。帕特里克接触的其他三个人属于灰色地带，反对同性婚姻，但方式让他看到了一丝希望。有一家来自犹他州的人，似乎对民事结合的想法持开放态度。还有一位朝鲜战争老兵。
I have no problem with people who are gay, or lesbians, or whatever. But I don't think they should get married. I think they should live together, have a lot of the protections of marriage, but I think that a marriage should be between a man a woman. So I may not be with you altogether.
我对同性恋者或女同性恋者什么的没有意见。但我不认为他们应该结婚。我认为他们应该住在一起，享有婚姻的许多保护，但我认为婚姻应该是在一男一女之间。所以我可能完全不同意你的观点。
Civil unions were fine with him, though. Patrick says that ever since Republicans started talking about outlawing gay marriage, at the federal level, tons of Republicans have been supporting civil unions, to a degree that he'd never imagined five years ago. He was very hopeful about the vet.
不过他支持民事结合。帕特里克说，自从共和党人开始讨论在联邦层面取缔同性婚姻以来，成千上万的共和党人开始支持民事结合，程度是他五年前从未想象过的。他对比这位老兵感到非常有希望。
He's one of those people that if he makes those inclusive-minded statements that he did, he's about 90% there. He's there on civil unions. He's there on not being bigoted towards gays and lesbians. So it's encouraging. He looked to be in his 60s. And if we have 60-year-old white, male veterans that are moving in towards our direction, that's a very good sign.
如果他能发表像他那样具有包容性的言论，他就已经完成了90%。他在民事结合问题上做到了。他在不对同性恋者偏执的问题上做到了。所以这很令人鼓舞。他看起来有60多岁了。如果我们有60多岁的白人男性退伍军人正在向我们的方向靠拢，那是一个非常好的迹象。
Hi. I'm Patrick Howell.
嗨，我是帕特里克·豪威尔。
Cindy White, North Carolina.
辛迪·怀特，北卡罗来纳州。
From Orlando, Florida.
来自佛罗里达州奥兰多。
Oh, Greensboro, North Carolina.
哦，北卡罗来纳州格林斯伯勒。
Oh, OK. Nice to meet you.
哦，好的。很高兴见到你。
Cindy White tells Patrick that Republicans in North Carolina are mostly against gay marriage. It's the Bible Belt, she says.
辛迪·怀特告诉帕特里克，北卡罗来纳州的共和党人大多反对同性婚姻。她说，这是圣经地带。
What would it take, do you think, to move you personally on the Federal Marriage Amendment?
你觉得，要改变你个人对《联邦婚姻修正案》的看法需要什么？
Oh, my brother-in-law lives in Key West and is gay.
哦，我的连襟住在基韦斯特，是同性恋。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
It doesn't mean I approve of marriage. But he's gay, and I approve of him.
这并不意味着我赞成同性婚姻。但他是个同性恋，我认可他这个人。
Right.
没错。
He hasn't married anyone. Doesn't want to, that I know of. But does have a partner. But it's just something I'm not ready to say exactly where I feel on it.
他没和任何人结婚。据我所知也不想结婚。但确实有伴侣。但这只是我还没有准备好明确表达自己感受的事情。
You might still be working on it, yourself.
你可能还在自己努力思考。
Yeah, might still be working on it.
是的，可能还在努力思考中。
Right.
没错。
At the end of talking to all these Republicans, the score was two against Patrick and gay rights, two for Patrick and gay rights, and three, like this last woman, that seemed like they might come around some day. Patrick felt pretty good. His sense, in general, is that people are more flexible than you know.
在与所有这些共和党人谈话结束后，比分是两个反对帕特里克和同性恋权利，两个支持帕特里克和同性恋权利，还有三个，像最后那位女士一样，似乎有一天可能会改变想法。帕特里克感觉相当不错。他总体的感受是，人们比你想象的要灵活。
I don't think that self-described social conservatives are as monolithic as a lot of people think. I think you do have social conservatives that keep an open mind, and may be very conservative in their religious views and whatnot, but at the same time have gay friends, and understand that they need to move a little bit on some of those issues. I think that's true more than it's not true.
我不认为自称社会保守派的人像许多人想象的那样铁板一块。我认为你确实有社会保守派思想开明，宗教观点可能非常保守，但同时也有同性恋朋友，并理解他们需要在这些问题上做出一点让步。我认为这种情况发生的几率比不发生的要大。
If you think about it, how many situations are there, where arch-conservative Christians and homosexuals sit down together and really hash things out. That's the point, Patrick says. We're inside the fortress. We're in these people's lives. We're talking to them. If anybody's going to get to these very conservative people on gay issues, it's going to be gay Republicans, not the protesters and activists who are outside the fortress.
如果你想一想，拱形保守的基督徒和同性恋者坐在一起深入讨论的情况有多少？重点就在这里，帕特里克说。我们在堡垒内部。我们进入了这些人的生活。我们在和他们交谈。如果有人能在同性恋议题上影响这些非常保守的人，那一定是同性恋共和党人，而不是堡垒外的抗议者和激进分子。
Act Two, Right and Righter. To understand the rise of the Republican Party over the last 20 years, one place you can look is Alabama, where they've made huge strides. If there is a religious and a nonreligious wing of the party, this is definitely the religious wing. Of the 48 delegates Alabama sent to the Republican Convention in New York, not one was pro-choice. Nationally, one out of three Republican Voters is pro-choice. 70% of the state identifies itself as born-again Christian, versus 40% nationally. Alex Blumberg visited with the Alabama Republican Party.
第二幕，“更右与最右”。要理解过去20年共和党的发展，你可以看看阿拉巴马州，他们取得了巨大的进步。如果党内有一个宗教派和一个非宗教派，这绝对是宗教派。在阿拉巴马州派往纽约参加共和党大会的48名代表中，没有一个是支持堕胎选择权的。在全国范围内，三分之一的共和党选民支持堕胎选择权。70%的该州居民自认为是重生基督徒，而全国平均水平为40%。亚历克斯·布隆伯格走访了阿拉巴马州共和党。
Marty Connors is the state chairman of the Republican Party in Alabama. He says that for Alabama, he's a moderate. He supports the war in Iraq 100%. He's opposed to any and all taxes. He wants Roe v. Wade to be overturned. And he would welcome prayer back into the public schools. But this is the state residents proudly call the buckle of the Bible Belt. So Marty Connors sometimes finds himself the most liberal person in the room.
马蒂·康纳斯是阿拉巴马州共和党的主席。他说，对于阿拉巴马州来说，他算是一个温和派。他百分之百支持伊拉克战争。他反对任何形式的税收。他希望《罗诉韦德案》被推翻。他欢迎祈祷回到公立学校。但这里被称为圣经地带的中心，所以马蒂·康纳斯有时发现自己是房间里最自由派的人。
A few years back, I was at a convention doing some whip work. And one of the delegates, who will go unnamed, felt that former President Bush-- who was then going to be vice president-- just wasn't conservative enough to be on the ticket. So he was going to support Gene Kirkpatrick for vice president, as opposed to George Bush. Which, Gene's great, but there's a time and place for everything.
几年前，我在参加一个会议做党鞭工作。其中一位代表（不便透露姓名）认为前总统布什（当时将成为副总统）还不够保守，不应出现在竞选名单上。所以他打算支持吉恩·柯克帕特里克担任副总统，而不是乔治·布什。吉恩很棒，但凡事有时间和地点。
And that would have meant, literally, what?
那在字面意义上意味着什么？
Well, Alabama being in the first state in the Union that has to-- the first state in the roll call, it would have looked a little awkward not having a unanimous-- So we decided to put him in a room, one-on-one with Jesse Helms for a little while, just to talk some sense, that kind of thing. So Jesse spent about 30 minutes with him. And the young man comes out of the room. And I said well, is everything fine? He said, oh, yeah. Everything's really fine. And I said, well, good. We'll have your support? He said, no, I'm still going to vote against you. And I said, well, why? And he said, well, Jesse Helms just doesn't completely understand the conservative movement. So that's how it went.
好吧，由于阿拉巴马州是第一个必须……在点名表决中排在第一位的州，没有全票通过看起来会有点尴尬……所以我们决定让他和杰西·赫尔姆斯单独待在一个房间里一会儿，去和他讲讲道理。杰西和他待了大约30分钟。这个年轻人走出房间。我说，一切都好了吗？他说，哦，是的。一切真的很好。我说，好的。我们会得到你的支持吗？他说，不，我还是会投你们的反对票。我说，为什么？他说，杰西·赫尔姆斯只是没有完全理解保守派运动。事情就是这样。
There are two informal wings in the Alabama Republican Party.
阿拉巴马州共和党内有两个非正式的派系。
This is Jim Zeigler, founder of a group called The League of Christian Voters, which represents the right wing of Alabama's right wing.
这是吉姆·齐格勒，一个名为“基督教选民联盟”组织的创始人，它代表了阿拉巴马州右翼的右翼。
There is an establishment, party official, chamber of commerce, business council, internationalist wing. And then there is the conservative Christian, adamantly pro-life, pro-family wing. Right now, the right wing, of which I am a part, is not in control of the party machinery. And I have appointed myself as the coordinator of the movement to take back the Republican Party for Republican principles.
存在一个建制派、党官僚、商会、商业理事会、国际主义者的派系。然后是保守的基督徒，坚决反堕胎、亲家庭的派系。目前，我所属的右翼并未控制党的机器。我已经任命自己为收回共和党原则运动的协调员。
Of course, in Alabama, both wings of the party are pro-life and begin their meetings with a prayer. So it can be a little hard to tell the two sides apart. The difference is mainly one of priorities. Business Republicans pray a lot, but Jim Zeigler's wing wants God to be at the very center of everything the government does.
当然，在阿拉巴马州，党的两个派系都是反堕胎的，会议都以祈祷开始。所以很难区分两派。区别主要在于优先事项。商业共和党人祈祷很多，但吉姆·齐格勒的派系希望上帝成为政府所做一切的核心。
In other words, it's the wing of Judge Roy Moore. Remember him? He was the Alabama chief justice who installed a 5,000 pound monument of the 10 Commandments in the state courthouse, and then was told to remove it by his own Republican-dominated bench. He later lost a job over it. Lots of Republicans didn't support Moore, or found him a little embarrassing. But the fact that the party didn't go to bat for him galvanized Jim Zeigler. He started The League of Christian Voters to try and get more Republicans like Judge Moore elected.
换句话说，这是罗伊·摩尔法官的派系。还记得他吗？他就是那位在州法院安装了5000磅重“十诫”纪念碑的阿拉巴马州首席大法官，后来被他自己共和党人占多数的法院要求拆除。他后来因此丢了工作。许多共和党人不支持摩尔，或者觉得他有点丢人。但党没有支持他这一事实激励了吉姆·齐格勒。他发起了“基督教选民联盟”，试图让更多像摩尔法官那样的共和党人当选。
The Republican Party does not need to have a broad tent. We need to focus on the issues of Republican principles.
共和党不需要大帐篷。我们需要专注于共和党原则的问题。
Here's how the Christian wing is doing so far. Out of three races for state judge this summer in the Republican Primary, they won one. And they make up about a third of the delegates at the Republican National Convention, 17 out of 48. One of those 17 was Zeigler himself, who became a delegate in a very symbolic race. He beat a man named Perry Hooper, Sr., who was one of the founders of the modern GOP in Alabama, the first Republican ever elected to the State Supreme Court, and one of the most respected centrists in the entire party. After his loss, Hooper called Zeigler an embarrassment to Christianity.
这是基督教派系目前的进展。今年夏天在共和党初选的三场州法官竞选中，他们赢了一场。他们占了共和党全国代表大会代表的三分之一，48人中有17人。这17人中的一人就是齐格勒本人，他在一场非常有象征意义的比赛中成为代表。他击败了一个名叫佩里·胡珀的人，他是现代阿拉巴马州共和党创始人之一，是第一个当选为州最高法院法官的共和党人，也是党内最受尊敬的中间派之一。失败后，胡珀称齐格勒是基督教的尴尬。
At this time, Bradley Byrne, state senator, will lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
现在，州参议员布拉德利·伯恩将带领我们宣誓效忠。
Thank you. Please cover your hearts.
谢谢。请捂住心脏。
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America.
我宣誓效忠美利坚合众国国旗。
On a Thursday night in the break room of Warrior Tractor, a farm equipment retailer in Monroeville, Alabama, I got a chance to see the moderate wing of the Republican Party. This is the largest meeting ever of the Monroe County Chapter of the Republican Party. People are turning Republican in Alabama faster than the Party infrastructure can keep up with them. For over a century, the state, like all its southern neighbors, had voted exclusively Democratic. You could fit all the Republicans in the state into one room, I'm told over and over again.
周四晚上，在阿拉巴马州门罗维尔的一家农机零售商Warrior Tractor的休息室里，我有机会看到了共和党温和派的一面。这是门罗县共和党分部有史以来规模最大的一次会议。阿拉巴马州加入共和党的人数增长速度超过了党内基础设施能够跟上的速度。一个多世纪以来，该州与其南方邻国一样，一直只投票给民主党。我一次又一次地被告知，全州所有的共和党人原本都可以挤进一个房间。
As late as 1992, Democrats controlled both of Alabama's seats in the US Senate, and five of the seven in the House of Representatives. Today, just a decade later, it's reversed. Five of the seven representatives and both senators are Republican, not to mention the governor and most of the State Supreme Court. There are about 100 people here, nibbling at pot luck offerings from Tupperware containers and casserole dishes. Mostly they're small business people. And mostly they want the standard Republican wish list. Smaller government, lower taxes, stronger military. But at some level, the issues are only part of the Republican draw. Kay Ivey, the state's first Republican treasurer, and featured speaker, puts it this way.
直到1992年，民主党还控制着阿拉巴马州在美国参议院的两个席位，以及七个众议院席位中的五个。今天，仅仅十年后，情况完全倒过来了。七名众议员中的五名和两名参议员都是共和党人，更不用说州长和州最高法院的大多数法官了。这里大约有100人，正在品尝特百惠容器和砂锅盘里的各式各样的自带食物。他们大多是小企业主。而且他们大多想要标准的共和党愿望清单。更小的政府、更低的税收、更强大的军事。但在某种程度上，这些议题只是共和党吸引力的一部分。该州第一位共和党财务主管、特邀发言人凯·艾维这样总结道。
You see, we in this room come from a same set of values. We cherish family, and patriotism, and hard work, and home ownership, and family and friends, and, goodness knows, the right to cook and eat. Y'all have done great. But you know, we care about people. And the president has the values that we have in this room tonight. And that's a clear distinction from his opponent.
你们看，我们这个房间里的人都有一套相同的价值观。我们珍视家庭、爱国主义、勤奋工作、拥有房产，以及家庭和朋友，天哪，还有烹饪和进食的权利。你们做得很好。但是你们知道，我们关心人民。总统拥有我们今晚在这个房间里所拥有的价值观。这与他的对手形成了鲜明的对比。
Later, a woman at the meeting tells me she can imagine George Bush walking right into this room, filled with these people, and fitting right in. But try as she might, she can't imagine John Kerry here. And actually, neither can I. Although Monroe County is almost 40% black, the crowd here is all white. And everyone admits the Party doesn't do too well with black people in Alabama. 19 out of every 20 black votes goes to a Democrat. And the state chairman was actually booed during a speech at Tuskegee University, when he mentioned Condoleezza Rice. Mainly this is historical. Lots of white voters in the South switched to the Republicans because of Democratic Party support for civil rights in the 60s.
后来，会议上的一位女士告诉我，她能想象乔治·布什直接走进这个满是这些人的房间，并完全融入其中。但无论她怎么努力，她都无法想象约翰·克里在这里。实际上，我也无法想象。尽管门罗县近40%的人口是黑人，但这里的人群全是白人。而且每个人都承认，在阿拉巴马州，该党在黑人中表现并不好。每20张黑人选票中就有19张投给民主党。州主席在塔斯基吉大学的一次演讲中提到康多莉扎·赖斯时，实际上被嘘了。这主要是历史原因。南方许多白人选民转向共和党，是因为民主党在60年代对民权运动的支持。
Today though, when a person with openly racist views decides to run on the Republican ticket, one Republican operative told me, the Party funnels back-channel money to the Democratic opponents, to make sure he doesn't get elected. And when visiting reporters come to town, the Party leadership introduces them to Shirrell Roberts, one of the black pioneers in the Alabama Republican Party. Shirrell's parents lived through the civil rights struggles in Alabama. And he lives in Montgomery, which is where, you remember, Martin Luther King's church was located, freedom riders were beaten at the bus station, and Rosa Parks refused to give up her seat.
不过今天，当一个持有公开种族主义观点的人决定以共和党候选人身份参选时，一位共和党工作人员告诉我，党部会通过秘密渠道向民主党对手输送资金，以确保他不会当选。当外地记者来到城里时，党部领导会把他们介绍给谢雷尔·罗伯茨，他是阿拉巴马州共和党内的黑人先驱之一。谢雷尔的父母经历过阿拉巴马州的民权斗争。他住在蒙哥马利，正如你们记得的那样，马丁·路德·金的教堂就在那里，自由骑行者在汽车站被殴打，罗莎·帕克斯拒绝让座。
I can understand the generation that was there, that lived it. I can understand the blacks that had the hose turned on them, the dogs put on them, absolutely. I don't expect those folks to get over it. And well, they shouldn't. And I understand exactly the hesitancy of a lot of blacks to say, hey, why would I want to join up with this group when you have the Willie Horton thing, Jesse Helms, what Trent Lott said about Strom Thurmond? Those type of things, specifically those, when I hear them, I'm like, look, that's not representative of our party.
我能理解那一代身处其中、亲身经历的人。我能理解那些被水龙冲过、被狗咬过的黑人，绝对能。我不指望这些人能放下。而且，他们也不应该放下。我完全理解许多黑人为何会犹豫，说：嘿，当你有威利·霍顿事件、杰西·赫尔姆斯、特伦特·洛特关于斯特罗姆·瑟蒙德的言论时，我为什么要加入这个群体？这类事情，特别是这些，当我听到它们时，我的想法是：看，那并不代表我们的党。
Shirrell's car has a Bush-Cheney bumper sticker. Driving around the neighborhood, he's been called a sellout and an Uncle Tom. He gets in political arguments with his Democrat mom all the time. Shirrell realized he was a Republican while watching the 1984 Democratic Convention with his family, when he heard Walter Mondale promise to raise taxes. Even as a kid, in a house of Mondale supporters, he hated that idea, proof that some people are just born Republican. Shirrell says that old-guard segregationists still occasionally show up in the party.
谢雷尔的车上有布什-切尼的保险杠贴纸。在社区里开车时，他被称为“叛徒”和“汤姆叔叔”。他经常和身为民主党人的妈妈吵政治。谢雷尔在和家人观看1984年民主党代表大会时意识到自己是共和党人，当时他听到沃尔特·蒙代尔承诺加税。即使作为孩子，在一个蒙代尔支持者的家里，他也很讨厌那个主意，这证明有些人天生就是共和党人。谢雷尔说，旧派种族隔离主义者偶尔还是会出现在党内。
But whenever I run into people like that, I just tell them, look, this country has changed. There is no way that you're going to be able to win an election anywhere with just a white vote. You aren't going to do it. You aren't going do it. And if that's your vision of our party, we will be the minority party for the rest of this century.
但每当我遇到那样的人，我就会告诉他们：看，这个国家已经变了。你不可能只靠白人选票赢得任何地方的选举。你做不到。你做不到。如果这就是你对我们党的愿景，我们将在本世纪剩下的时间里成为少数党。
Shirrell is pro-life, wants smaller government. He's for the war in Iraq. But most of our conversation was spent on the subject of inequality-- racial and economic inequality-- which isn't one of your usual Republican talking points.
谢雷尔反堕胎，想要更小的政府。他支持伊拉克战争。但我们的大部分对话都花在了不平等问题上——种族和经济不平等——这并不是你通常的共和党谈话要点。
If there's a problem in the black community, it affects the white community as well. If there's a problem in the white community, it affects the black community. And people have to realize we're all in this thing together. Let's not have one community very prosperous, but over here have another segment of the community that's not doing well.
如果黑人社区有问题，它也会影响白人社区。如果白人社区有问题，它也会影响黑人社区。人们必须意识到，我们都在这条船上。不要让一个社区非常繁荣，而这里却有另一个社区的某个阶层过得不好。
I don't have a responsibility to educate a child here in Montgomery. I live 150 miles away. My wife and I have two children. I don't have children with anybody else. I'm responsible for educating them.
我没有责任教育蒙哥马利的某个孩子。我住在150英里之外。我和妻子有两个孩子。我和其他人没有孩子。我有责任教育他们。
You have to hand it to a political party that can claim both of these guys as loyal members. Steven King is a self-described right wing Christian and the chairman of the Blount County Republican Party. On most issues, it's not that he and Shirrell believe different things, it's just that Steven King believes them more. He's more of a free marketeer, thinks government should almost not exist, and on religious issues, he's less of a compromiser.
你必须佩服一个能将这两个人都视为忠诚成员的政党。史蒂文·金是一位自称右翼基督徒的共和党人，也是布朗特县共和党的主席。在大多数问题上，并不是他和谢雷尔的信仰不同，只是史蒂文·金信得更深。他更倾向于自由市场，认为政府几乎不应该存在，而在宗教问题上，他更不妥协。
I would rather be right on an issue and lose, than be wrong and win. We misuse the word big tent, I think. I'm sure there are people in the Republican Party are homosexuals. You've got the Log Cabin Republicans. They want to become Republicans, fine. My viewpoint is we're still going to have a position on our plank that we're not going to be for homosexual marriage.
我宁愿在议题上正确却失败，也不愿错误却成功。我认为我们误用了“大帐篷”这个词。我相信共和党内有同性恋者。有“原木小屋”共和党人。他们想成为共和党人，随他们便。我的观点是，我们的纲领上仍然会坚持我们不赞成同性恋婚姻的立场。
People in the Christian wing, like Steven King, because they're motivated by their idealism and care less about political majorities, can find themselves in a paradoxical position. They're the Party's most conservative members. But sometimes they sound like its most liberal critics.
基督教派系的人像史蒂文·金一样，因为他们受理想主义驱使，不太关心政治多数，这使他们处于一种矛盾的境地。他们是党内最保守的成员。但有时他们听起来却像党内最自由派的批评者。
Steven King, for example, doesn't trust the Patriot Act. He's opposed to tort reform, and don't even get him started about that secret meeting Dick Cheney held a while back with energy industry representatives. The vice president has refused to release even a list of the people who attended. And Steven King says that's the same type of thing that Republicans got mad at President Clinton about when he appointed his wife, Hillary, to head a panel on health care.
例如，史蒂文·金不信任《爱国者法案》。他反对侵权法改革，甚至别让他谈论迪克·切尼前段时间与能源行业代表举行的那次秘密会议。副总统拒绝公布哪怕一份出席者的名单。史蒂文·金说，这和当初克林顿总统任命他的妻子希拉里领导医疗保健小组时，共和党人对他感到愤怒的事情是一样的。
Who are these people? It's my tax money. Too many people on my side of the aisle, or my side of the position, and the other side of the spectrum, I don't think are intellectually honest. I mean, you can't say that when the Democrats are there and they get some health care panel together, that everything ought to be all open. And Mr. Cheney comes along, and well, that's a different thing. Well, no, it's not different.
这些人是谁？这是我的税钱。我这一方的人，或者我立场这一方，以及光谱的另一端，有太多人我认为在智力上是不诚实的。我的意思是，你不能说当民主党人在那里，他们搞起医疗小组时，一切都应该公开。而切尼先生来了，嗯，那是另一回事。不，那并没什么不同。
Like many idealistic people, Steven King has a complicated relationship to politics. He's drawn to it, but he also feels let down by it. He still remembers, as a kid, begging his parents to stay up and watch the '72 Convention on TV, to see Nixon get nominated. All those people with all those deeply held convictions coming together to argue and persuade. It seemed romantic, like the first Constitutional Convention, when the country was being founded.
像许多理想主义者一样，史蒂文·金与政治有着复杂的关系。他被它吸引，但也感到被它辜负。他仍然记得小时候恳求父母熬夜看电视上的72年代表大会，看尼克松被提名。那些人带着深厚的信念聚在一起争论和说服。那看起来很浪漫，就像第一次制宪会议，当国家正在建立时。
I guess I thought, in some ways, that was what was going on at a convention. I realize now that those things don't happen, or don't happen, I guess, the way that I thought about it then.
我想，在某些方面，我以为这就是代表大会上发生的事情。我现在意识到那些事情并没有发生，或者说，我猜，并没有像我当时想象的那样发生。
Was that a disappointment, to find out that they don't happen that way?
发现它们不是那样发生的，是一种失望吗？
Yeah. I was a delegate four years ago in Philadelphia. And I was, I guess, naive. And I learned that my participation was very, very limited, almost to the point of simply being a warm body in a chair. I've been a Republican my whole life. You want to have a say-so. This is what I believe, and this is why I believe it. And they don't-- I don't want to say they don't want to hear it. but that's just not what you're there for.
是的。四年前在费城我是一名代表。我想我是天真的。我了解到我的参与非常、非常有限，几乎只是单纯作为一个坐在椅子上的肉体。我一生都是共和党人。你想要有发言权。这是我的信仰，这就是我为何相信它。他们并不……我不想说他们不想听，但那根本不是你在那里的目的。
This, it sometimes seems, is what you are here for, to drink free booze and dance awkwardly to cover bands. It's the week of the GOP Convention in New York. A couple of the delegates at this party have a line on some Skynyrd tickets for later. It's a private concert for the GOP conventioneers. And even though this is the largest assembly of Republicans for the next four years, and even though there's every kind of Republican present here-- including a drunk one at the bar, who confided in me late in the evening that he's voting for Kerry-- even here, Steven King can't get what he wants.
这有时看起来就是你在这里的目的：喝免费的酒，伴随着翻唱乐队笨拙地跳舞。这是纽约共和党大会的一周。参加聚会的几位代表有几张Lynyrd Skynyrd乐队的门票。这是为共和党大会参加者举办的私人音乐会。即使这是未来四年内共和党规模最大的一次集会，即使在场有各种各样的共和党人——包括吧台上一位醉醺醺的人，深夜向我透露他要投票给克里——即使在这里，史蒂文·金也得不到他想要的。
The thing I want is for there to be debate, to be open discussion. I want someone to allow me to try to convince them otherwise. And I'm open to be convinced otherwise. Let's engage in debate. Otherwise, we're just this mish mash goosh of feel good, which doesn't mean anything.
我想要的是辩论，是公开讨论。我想要有人允许我试着说服他们。我也愿意被对方说服。让我们进行辩论吧。否则，我们只是这种感觉良好的乱炖，毫无意义。
That story by Alex Blumberg. Coming up, Steven King gets his wish, a real debate, the kind that rarely happens in American politics. We have him sit down with Patrick Howell, the Log Cabin Republican from the first act of our show, mano-a-mano. Who will convince whom? That's in the second half of our show, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
那是亚历克斯·布隆伯格的故事。接下来，史蒂文·金实现了他的愿望，一场真正的辩论，那种在美国政治中极少发生的辩论。我们让他和我们节目第一幕中的“原木小屋”共和党人帕特里克·豪威尔坐下来，一对一。谁会说服谁？那将在我们节目的下半部分，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, stories about America's majority party. And yes, they are just barely the majority. But it's the Republicans whose numbers are rising. In the second half of our show, we have two stories of people in this charged political environment this fall trying to come to a meeting of the minds. We'll pick up with Alabama's Steven King again in a little bit. Where we turn now is to a visit to a different wing of the party, people who are Republicans, but not for religious reasons, but for economic ones. 70% of Republicans approve of the way that President Bush is handling the economy. That's versus just 22% of Democrats who approve. We have arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Indecent Proposal. Shane DuBow tells the story of Republicans who work in a place where everyone is thinking about the economy and its ups and downs all the time.
这是《这美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，是关于美国多数党的故事。是的，他们只是刚刚达到多数。但共和党的人数正在上升。在我们节目的下半部分，有两个关于这个秋天充满政治色彩的环境中，人们试图达成共识的故事。我们稍后再接上阿拉巴马州的史蒂文·金。我们现在要转向党的另一个派系，那些是共和党人，但不是出于宗教原因，而是经济原因。70%的共和党人认可布什总统处理经济的方式。相比之下，只有22%的民主党人认可。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“不雅提议”。肖恩·杜博讲述了共和党人在一个人们时刻都在思考经济涨跌的地方工作的故事。
Every election season, a company-wide email goes out at my work. The email reminds everyone that our office is supposed to be a politics-free zone. The subtext is all about keeping things civil and productive. At my friend Mike's work, that's not how they do it.
每个选举季，我的工作地点都会发出全公司范围的邮件。邮件提醒每个人我们的办公室应该是一个“无政治区”。潜台词是关于保持文明和高效。在我朋友迈克工作的地点，他们不是这么做的。
Come here. I want to talk to you a second. Come here.
过来。我想和你谈谈。过来。
This is the cattle pit of the Chicago Mercantile Exchange. It's the morning after Arnold Schwarzenegger and Rudy Giuliani have given speeches at the Republican National Convention in New York.
这是芝加哥商品交易所的牛市交易场。这是阿诺德·施瓦辛格和鲁迪·朱利安尼在纽约共和党全国代表大会上发表演讲后的第二天早上。
Come out here for a second, if you get a second. One second. You are not that busy. Come out here. He said, economic girly man That's the big refrain today. What? They call me liberal boy. And they get the refrain from Schwarzenegger-- that economic girly man. I've heard it all morning. I mean, between Giuliani's speech bashing Kerry and the economic girly man, it has been a bad two days to be down here. Put it that way.
过来这里一下，如果你有空的话。一秒钟。你没那么忙。过来。他说，“经济娘娘腔”。那是今天的大主题。什么？他们叫我“自由派男孩”。他们引用施瓦辛格的话——那个“经济娘娘腔”。我一整个上午都在听。我的意思是，在朱利安尼抨击克里的演讲和“经济娘娘腔”之间，当这里的人这两天真是不好过。就是这样。
What Mike means is that it has been a bad two days to be one of the only outspoken Democrats in a testosterone-charged pit full of some of the most right-leaning and red meat-eating traders on the floor. Every day, all day, he gets heckled. During the election season it gets worse. With that in mind, Mike has come up with this idea, this way to win a few converts, or at least score a few political points. His plan? Take some of these guys to see the Michael Moore movie Fahrenheit 9/11. And to get them to go, he's offering cash.
迈克的意思是，作为一个充满睾酮、满是右倾和爱吃红肉的交易员组成的场子里仅有的几个直言不讳的民主党人之一，这两天真是不好过。每天，整天，他都被人嘲讽。选举季期间情况更糟。考虑到这一点，迈克想出了这个主意，这个赢得几个支持者、或者至少赢得几分政治分数的办法。他的计划？带这些人去看看迈克尔·摩尔的电影《华氏9/11》。为了让他们去，他提供现金。
I'm paying $400 a crack to go. It's $400. I got some takers. You can wager it in Vegas. It's $400, and I'll even throw in a drink afterwards. We're going to see Fahrenheit 9/11 . Are you going to come with us?
我每次支付400美元。400美元。我有一些愿意参加的人。你可以在拉斯维加斯下注。400美元，事后我还请喝酒。我们要去看《华氏9/11》。你要和我们一起去吗？
No.
不去。
What?
什么？
After a month of trying and failing to make this movie thing happen, he has finally found some takers, Bill and Tom.
在一个月尝试并失败让这部电影的事情发生后，他终于找到了几个愿意的人，比尔和汤姆。
Well, we have a long relationship. We have a 10-year relationship, all of us on the floor. And it tends to be me against-- tends to be me against the pit. And Tom tends to be the leader on the other side. And he has quite a lot of help.
好吧，我们关系很深。我们有10年的关系，我们所有人都在场内。往往是我对抗……往往是我对抗整个交易场。而汤姆往往是另一方的领导者。他有相当多的帮手。
And he's not even close to being on his soapbox yet.
而且他甚至还没上他的讲坛呢。
This is Bill.
这是比尔。
Two days ago we had a nice little chat. And three rows down-- we were sitting in those stadium seats way at the top-- everybody's turning around and looking up, because Mike is screaming about, "These people are lying. Did you read this in the paper? They're absolutely lying! These Republicans--"
两天前我们聊得很好。在三排之下……我们坐在那些体育场式的最高座位上……每个人都转过身抬头看，因为迈克在尖叫：“这些人都在撒谎。你们在报纸上读到这个了吗？他们绝对在撒谎！这些共和党人……”
The political arguments these guys get into will probably sound familiar. There's the one about terrorism.
这些家伙陷入的政治辩论你们可能听起来很熟悉。有一个是关于恐怖主义的。
Under your man's administration for eight years, we ignored all the signs.
在你们那人八年的管理下，我们忽视了所有迹象。
The one about the economy.
有一个关于经济。
You think Clinton can take credit for the tech boom? Are you out of your-- Oh, come one, seriously.
你认为克林顿能把科技繁荣归功于自己？你是不是……哦，别这样，认真的。
No, no, no.
不，不，不。
The other one about the economy.
另一个关于经济。
The junior, Bush Junior drove it into the ditch. I mean come on. The father drove the economy into the ditch. And then Bush Junior drove it into the ditch.
小布什，布什二世把它开进了沟里。我的意思是拜托。老布什把经济开进了沟里。然后布什二世又把它开进了沟里。
Oh, man.
哦，天哪。
And then there's whatever you call this.
然后还有不管你怎么称呼这个。
I consider myself a political moderate.
我自认为是个政治温和派。
Really.
真的。
Oh, my God. That's the problem. You think you're a moderate.
哦，天哪。这就是问题所在。你以为你是温和派。
I'm a moderate.
我是温和派。
You're a moderate?
你是温和派？
I'm a moderate. I'm right in the center. I'm a Clintonian. In fact, I love Bill Clinton. He tacked the country right to the middle.
我是温和派。我就在中心。我是克林顿派。事实上，我爱比尔·克林顿。他把国家拉回了中间。
What?
什么？
He tacked the country right--
他把国家拉回……
He attacked every chick in his office.
他攻击了他办公室里的每个女孩。
No, no, no. He tacked--
不，不，不。他拉回了……
Tom is 49, tall and good looking, a former college basketball player. In Tom's world, the flat tax is the fairest tax, Fox is the fairest network, and nationalized health care will lead to socialism. Growing up, Tom says, his family didn't have a lot of money.
汤姆49岁，高大帅气，曾是大学篮球运动员。在汤姆的世界里，单一税是最公平的税，福克斯是最公平的电视网，国有化医疗保障将导致社会主义。汤姆说，成长过程中，他的家庭并没有很多钱。
You talk about the political girly man. Hey, you know what? I put myself through college. Nobody gave me a dime. You didn't do that.
你谈论政治娘娘腔。嘿，你知道吗？我靠自己上完了大学。没人给过我一毛钱。你没做到那样。
He's looking straight at Mike here.
他直视着迈克。
I've been working since I was in fifth grade. And no one has ever given me anything. I don't feel sorry for people that sit around and wait for entitlements. You shouldn't call it an entitlement. It's welfare. It's not entitlement. You're not entitled to squat.
我从五年级就开始工作了。从来没有人给过我任何东西。我不为那些坐等福利的人感到难过。你不应该称之为“权利”。它是救济。那不是权利。你对任何东西都没有权利。
As for Bill, he's also an independent broker who had to work growing up. And he also doesn't think much of taxes or welfare, which brings us back to Mike, and his hopes for Michael Moore's latest movie.
至于比尔，他也是一个成长过程中不得不工作的独立经纪人。他对比税收或救济也没什么好感，这又回到了迈克和他对比尔·摩尔最新电影的希望上。
Fahrenheit 9/11 came out. All of the people, the conservatives, the people that I talked to in the pit, no one had seen the movie. No one had seen the movie. They would critique the hell out of the movie, but they wouldn't go see it. So I started--
《华氏9/11》上映了。所有的人，保守派，我在交易场交谈过的人，没人看过这部电影。没人看过这部电影。他们会把电影批评得体无完肤，但他们就是不去看。所以我开始……
Is that true? No one wanted to see the movie?
那是真的吗？没人想看那部电影？
The reason for that is because you knew that, for example, Michael Moore's previous stuff. He mixes some facts with some non-facts, and this is your story.
原因是你知道，例如，迈克尔·摩尔以前的作品。他把一些事实和一些非事实混在一起，这就是你们的故事。
All right, hold on here. This is the kind of thing that I have to endure. Hold on.
好了，等一下。这就是我必须忍受的那种东西。等一下。
I'll say something else.
我要再说一点。
OK, no, you've been talking the whole time now. This is what happens in the pit. People are quoting everything else they read about the movie, but they won't see it, OK? And that is the premise that I've operated under. So the way this started is a guy that is in my next office comes in one day, is quoting the same stuff, saying, oh, it's so terrible, what Michael Moore is doing to the country with this movie.
好了，不，你一直都在说。这就是交易场里发生的事。人们引用他们读到的关于电影的一切，但他们不去看，好吗？这就是我运作的前提。所以这开始的方式是，一个在我也在的办公室工作的家伙有一天进来了，引用同样的东西，说，哦，太糟糕了，迈克尔·摩尔用这部电影对国家做了什么。
And I say, Fred, have you seen the movie? And he says, no, I haven't seen the movie. I said, OK, what's it going to take to get you to go to the movie? And he says, my time is worth more than going to see a movie. I said, well, what's your time worth? He says, well, I'm paid $200 an hour as a consultant. And I said, OK. The movie is two hours. How about $400?
我对他说，弗雷德，你看了那部电影吗？他说，不，我没看。我说，好的，要让你去看电影需要什么条件？他说，我的时间比看电影值钱。我说，好的，你的时间值多少钱？他说，嗯，我作为顾问每小时薪水200美元。我说，好的。电影是两个小时。400美元怎么样？
There seems like there's a political debate going on in the country, and no one's listening to each other. So one side talks to their brethren, the other side talks to their brethren, and we're not having any cross-fertilization. There's no dialogue happening. And one of the most fundamental things in a democracy is to have a dialogue.
国内似乎正在进行一场政治辩论，但没人听别人的。所以一边和自己的兄弟对话，另一边和自己的兄弟对话，我们没有交叉授粉。没有任何对话发生。民主国家最基本的事情之一就是进行对话。
Even before the main feature, it's clear Bill and Tom are ready to find liberal plots behind whatever they see. Example. When a preview for the new shark movie Open Water comes on, and a young couple is shown treading water, Tom and Bill make jokes about Chappaquiddick. I asked Mike for a few predictions.
即使在正片之前，很明显比尔和汤姆也准备好在他们看到的任何东西背后寻找自由派的阴谋。例子。当新鲨鱼电影《深海狂鲨》的预告片播放，年轻夫妇被展示在踩水时，汤姆和比尔开起了关于查帕奎迪克事件的笑话。我让迈克做几个预测。
Which one of these guys do you think is most vulnerable to slipping over to the real side?
你认为这两个人中谁最容易倒向现实的一边？
Which one of these two, sitting in front of me? I think Tom is pretty vulnerable on this one. And I think it's going to be one of those things, if this does make him break--
这两个坐在我面前的人？我认为汤姆在这方面相当容易动摇。而且我认为这将是那种事情，如果这真的让他转变的话……
Mike, I want you closer to me so I can hear you bad-mouthing me.
迈克，我要你离我近一点，这样我就能听见你背后诋毁我了。
I'm not bad-mouthing you. He asked me which one of you guys are going to come over to the other side after you see this thing.
我没有背后诋毁你。他问我你们这两个人中谁在看完这个东西后会倒向另一边。
I'll put it this way. G. Gordon Liddy is too middle of the road for me.
我可以这样说。G·戈登·利迪对我来说都太中间派了。
See? I think he's ready. I think he's primed for a conversion. I think he's primed for a conversion. You know, you get your most extreme right before you decide to change.
看到了吗？我认为他准备好了。我认为他准备好转变了。我认为他准备好转变了。你知道，在你决定改变之前，你处于最极端的右翼。
The movie starts. Right away, Mike's bid to win these guys over seems in trouble. Here is an early scene showing black members of Congress protesting the 2000 election results in a joint session. Al Gore is presiding as president of the senate.
电影开始了。迈克赢得这些人的投标似乎立即陷入困境。这是一个早期的场景，显示国会的黑人议员在联席会议上抗议2000年的选举结果。戈尔作为参议院议长主持会议。
Is the objection in writing, and signed by a member of the House and a senator?
异议是否是以书面形式，并由一名众议员和一名参议员签署的？
The objection is in writing. And I don't care that it is not signed by a member--
异议是以书面形式提出的。我不关心它是否由议员签署……
That's the beauty of liberals. They don't care about the rules.
这就是自由派的美妙之处。他们不在乎规则。
When Richard Clarke, former White House terrorism czar, explains how President Bush was obsessed with invading Iraq, even before September 11, Bill whispers that Clarke had an axe to grind, because he got passed over for a promotion. And Tom says, "Right, so he's bitter. They're interviewing a bitter ex-employee." Even the movie's celebrity walk-ons get the treatment.
当理查德·克拉克，前白宫恐怖主义主管，解释布什总统是多么痴迷于入侵伊拉克，甚至在9月11日之前，比尔低声说克拉克有私心，因为他错过了晋升机会。汤姆说：“对，所以他很痛苦。他们在采访一个痛苦的前雇员。”甚至电影的明星客串也受到了同样对待。
Look, there's Ben Affleck. He's often in my dreams.
看，那是本·阿弗莱克。他经常出现在我的梦里。
I'll bet he is.
我敢打赌他确实会出现。
You get the idea. Sarcastic comments from Tom, dismissive chitchat from Bill. A lot of hopeful, see? See what I means? from Mike. And every now and then, a moment of silence, when it's hard to tell how exactly the movie is going over. By the end, though, Mike seems encouraged.
你明白了。汤姆的讽刺评论，比尔的轻蔑闲聊。迈克充满希望的“看见了吗？看见我指的意思了吗？”。偶尔会出现一阵沉默，很难说电影具体是怎么被接受的。不过到最后，迈克似乎受到了鼓励。
As we leave the theater, he asks Tom about a few scenes, like the one where Bush, at a black tie fundraiser, first dubs the crowd a collection of haves and have mores, and then says, "Some people call you the elite. I call you my base."
当我们离开影院时，他问汤姆几个场景，比如布什在黑领结晚宴上，第一次称人群为“有钱人和更有钱人的集合”，然后说：“有些人称你们为精英。我称你们为我的基本盘。”
You know, you're the kind of person that wasn't born in the elites of the country, right? And so, when Bush gets up and he says I'm here with-- wait, wait, hold on. He says I'm here with the mores and have mores, does that appeal do you, intrinsically?
你知道，你那种不是出生在国家精英阶层的人，对吧？所以，当布什站起来说我和……等等，等一下。他说我和有钱人和更有钱人在一起，这本质上对你有吸引力吗？
It doesn't appeal to me, but it was a joke and it was funny. He's making a joke, and it was a funny joke. It wasn't like he was disparaging anyone. He just said-- because that's who was there.
这对我没吸引力，但那是个笑话，而且很有趣。他在开玩笑，那是个有趣的玩笑。这不像他在轻视任何人。他只是说……因为那是当时在场的人。
I asked Tom and Bill if anything in the movie, anything at all, struck a chord. Tom mentions the part where Bush is said to have opposed better pay and benefits for soldiers. He says if that's true, it's disturbing. Bill agrees. Both men say they'll go home and do some research, see if Michael Moore's quote unquote "facts" check out.
我问汤姆和比尔电影里是否有什么东西，哪怕只有一点点，触动了他们的心弦。汤姆提到了布什据称反对为士兵提供更好的薪酬和福利的部分。他说如果那是真的，那令人不安。比尔表示同意。两人都说他们会回家做些研究，看看迈克尔·摩尔所谓的“事实”是否经得起推敲。
Well, you know what? The problem with Moore is so much of his premise is riddled with half truths and lies. So I'd like to find out what really was the deal with that. I mean, I just can't believe that's true.
嗯，你知道吗？摩尔的问题在于他的很多前提都充满了半真半假和谎言。所以我很想知道那件事到底是怎么回事。我的意思是，我就是不相信那是真的。
They don't even believe one of the points in the movie that's actually backed up by the Independent and Bipartisan 9/11 Commission, that there's no meaningful link between Al Qaeda and Iraq.
他们甚至不相信电影中实际上得到独立和两党9/11委员会支持的一点，即基地组织和伊拉克之间没有有意义的联系。
I don't believe that for a minute. I don't care who tells me. I don't believe that for a minute.
我一分钟都不信。我不在乎是谁告诉我的。我一分钟都不信。
Then Bill weighs in on the one part of the movie I thought might be persuasive, the part where the pro-military mother from Flint, Michigan loses her son in Iraq.
然后比尔谈到了电影中我认为可能具有说服力的一部分，那个来自密歇根州弗林特的亲军事母亲在伊拉克失去了儿子的部分。
I thought he really belabored that. I thought he was really staid on that. And in particular, when she was in Washington, and then she's breaking down crying, well, I'm sitting there thinking, well, geez, here's this poor woman falling down crying, and you're just stand there filming. Typical press deal.
我觉得他真的太啰嗦了。我觉得他在这方面真的太刻板了。特别是当她在华盛顿，然后她崩溃大哭时，我就坐在那里想，好吧，天哪，这是个可怜的女人倒地大哭，而你就站在那里拍摄。典型的媒体那一套。
Right.
没错。
It's at this point that Tom turns, reaches into his back pocket, and pulls out a wad of folded papers he's printed off the internet.
就在这时，汤姆转过身，伸手进后裤兜，掏出一叠他从网上打印出来的折叠纸。
Oh, that's something about all the untruths in the movie, though?
哦，那是关于电影里的所有谎言之类的东西吗？
Not all of them, just a handful of them.
不是全部，只是一小部分。
Oh, you had it going in. You didn't show me that.
哦，你进去之前就有了。你没给我看那个。
Well, what am I--?
嗯，我应该干什么……？
Did you read all these before you came into the movie today?
你在今天进入电影之前读了所有这些吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So you were prepared.
所以你是有准备的。
What am I supposed to do? Come in here like a sheep to be sheared by you? By you and your left-wing liberal friends, trying to corner me just like Michael Moore? Trying to ambush me?
我应该干什么？像绵羊一样进来被你剪毛吗？被你和你的左翼自由派朋友，像迈克尔·摩尔一样试图围堵我？试图伏击我？
In the entire 10-year history of these arguments, and these discussions, has anyone ever been persuaded?
在这些争论和讨论的整个10年历史中，有人被说服过吗？
Absolutely not.
绝对没有。
That is a problem. And that's the thing. I was thinking, because people say, why are you going to this thing today? And I said, well, I have got to straighten some liberals out about a few things. And I said it in a joking manner, because the fact of the matter is, no matter what you do, I think people are wired differently. I mean, I've tried to straighten out Mike several times. But he's wired different. No matter what I show him, to show him that I'm right and he's wrong, he could agree with me on all this stuff, and then he'll still say, no, I'm still supporting Democrats.
这是一个问题。就是这样。我在想，因为人们说，为什么你今天要去这个东西？我说，嗯，我得纠正一些自由派关于某些事情的看法。而且我是开玩笑说的，因为事实是，无论你做什么，我认为人们的思维方式不同。我的意思是，我曾多次试图纠正迈克。但他思维不同。无论我给他看什么，证明我是对的他是错的，他都可以同意我所有这些东西，然后他还是会说，不，我还是要支持民主党人。
Mike doesn't exactly see it that way. He's still surprisingly hopeful, even though he's worked on these guys for seven straight hours, including the movie. And to me it seems like they haven't budged.
迈克并不完全那样看。他仍然出人意料地充满希望，尽管他在这些人身上花了整整七个小时，包括看电影。在我看来，他们似乎一点都没动摇。
Tom will never really cede any ground in an argument, but I did see a door open, go ajar there. A little doubt entered his mind when he saw that the military benefits had been cut for the veterans. And I think that really bothered him. And it's a war of attrition with these guys. And by God, I'm going to work on them tomorrow morning, in the pit, with this thing.
汤姆永远不会在争论中真正让步，但我确实看到了一扇门打开了一道缝。当他看到退伍军人的军事福利被削减时，他心中产生了一丝怀疑。我认为那真的困扰了他。这是一场与这些人的消耗战。而且上帝作证，我明天早上要在交易场上用这个东西继续努力。
When I call Mike for an update, he says that for a few days after the movie, he got more grief than ever out on the trading floor. Tom brought in a copy of Zell Miller's Republican Convention speech, and took to reading it out loud whenever there was a lull. But then all the politics started to wear people out. The back and forth got old and the teasing died down. And then just when things were returning to normal, Mike says, two other Republican traders approached him on the floor. They had gone to see Fahrenheit 9/11 on their own, they said. They each wanted their $400.
当我打电话询问迈克进展时，他说电影上映后的几天里，他在交易大厅里受到了比以往更多的挫折。汤姆带来了一份泽尔·米勒共和党大会演讲的副本，并在有空档时大声朗读。但随后所有的政治活动开始让人疲惫不堪。来回的争论变得陈旧，戏弄也消失了。就在事情恢复正常时，迈克说，另外两名共和党交易员在场内接近了他。他们说他们自己去看了《华氏9/11》。他们每个人都想要他们的400美元。
Shane DuBow, in Chicago.
肖恩·杜博，在芝加哥。
Act Four, It's My Party. So Steven King, Christian Republican from Alabama, came to the Republican Convention in New York, wanting to debate the issues. And Patrick Howell, gay Republican from Florida, came to the Convention wanting to debate the issues. So it only seems right that somebody, somebody, would get those two crazy kids together.
第四幕，“这是我的派对”。所以史蒂文·金，来自阿拉巴马州的基督教共和党人，来到纽约共和党大会，想要辩论议题。帕特里克·豪威尔，来自佛罗里达州的同性恋共和党人，来到大会想要辩论议题。所以，让某个人，让某个人，把这两个疯狂的孩子凑在一起，似乎是正确的。
Hi. Steve King.
嗨。史蒂夫·金。
Patrick Howell.
帕特里克·豪威尔。
Nice to meet you, Patrick.
很高兴见到你，帕特里克。
Nice to meet you, too.
也很高兴见到你。
They hit it off right away. Patrick, it turns out-- and two brothers and a sister-- went to school up in Alabama, at Samford University, the Baptist school where, coincidentally, Steven got his law degree. Patrick was Sigma Nu. So was Steven's brother. Patrick's sister still lives a few miles from Birmingham. Steven knew the town and the high school her kids are going to.
他们立刻一拍即合。事实证明，帕特里克（有两个兄弟一个姐妹）在阿拉巴马州的桑福德大学上过学，那是一所浸信会学校，巧合的是，史蒂文在那里获得了法学学位。帕特里克是Sigma Nu成员。史蒂文的兄弟也是。帕特里克的姐姐仍然住在伯明翰附近几英里处。史蒂文知道那个小镇以及她孩子要上的高中。
I live just north of Birmingham, about 30 miles, in Blount County, Oneonta.
我住在伯明翰北边，大约30英里，在布朗特县的奥尼昂塔。
OK. Do you know the Phillips family?
好的。你认识菲利普斯一家吗？
Yeah. You know Derick?
是的。你认识德里克吗？
Yeah, Derick was a fraternity brother of mine.
是的，德里克是我兄弟会的兄弟。
Oh, you're kidding.
哦，你在开玩笑吧。
Yeah.
是的。
After a few minutes of Southern comfortableness, they got down to business. Patrick said that while of course he and Steven would agree that our country was founded on Judeo-Christian principles, our idea of those principles changes over time. Slavery was abolished. Women got the right to vote. And it's the same with rights for gays and lesbians, he said.
经过几分钟南方式的舒适交谈，他们进入了正题。帕特里克说，虽然他当然同意史蒂文关于我们的国家建立在犹太-基督教原则之上的观点，但我们对这些原则的构想是随着时间变化的。奴隶制被废除了。妇女获得了投票权。他说，同性恋者的权利也是一样。
And, you know, it's difficult for us, when social conservatives come at us from two angles. They come at us from the angle of saying, you're immoral, you sleep around, you can't settle down and have one relationship. And then on the other side, the same people are saying, we're not going to let you enter into relationships. We don't want you to. And that's frustrating for us, when you hear that coming from both sides of someone's mouth.
而且，你知道，当社会保守派从两个角度向我们进攻时，我们感到困难。他们从这个角度攻击我们，说：你们是不道德的，你们滥交，你们不能安顿下来拥有稳定的关系。然后另一方面，同样的人在说：我们不允许你们进入那种关系。我们不希望你们那样。当我们听到有人两头都这么说时，这对我们来说很令人沮丧。
Because that's what we want. We want to be boring. That's what we're fighting for, is to be boring, and to just settle down with someone and spend the rest of our lives with them. What are your thoughts on maybe coming to some sort of middle ground, that would allow for civil unions and protections like that?
因为这正是我们想要的。我们想要变得无聊。我们正在为之奋斗的就是变得无聊，只是和某个人安定下来，共度余生。对于允许某种民事结合和类似的保护措施，或许能达成某种中间立场，你有什么想法？
With respect to coming to some kind of common ground, or middle ground, we probably can on some level. And there's going to be other levels we won't be able to. I'm never going to agree that homosexuality, or that lifestyle, is a moral lifestyle. Reading God's word, I'm never going to come to that position. One thing I sense from the homosexual lobby-- I'll call it that-- is that I get a sense it's not just whether you want to be able to have civil unions, or marriage, or whatever. It's that you want me-- or people who believe like me-- not just to accept your homosexuality, but that homosexuality is OK.
关于达成某种共同立场或中间立场，我们可能在某个层面上可以做到。而在其他层面上我们将无法做到。我永远不会同意同性恋或那种生活方式是一种道德的生活方式。阅读上帝的话语，我永远不会达到那种立场。我从同性恋游说团体（我姑且这么称呼它）身上感受到的一点是，我感觉这不仅仅是你是否希望能够拥有民事结合或婚姻或其他什么的问题。而是你希望我——或像我这样信仰的人——不仅仅接受你们的同性恋，而是认为同性恋是“没问题”的。
No. I don't think that that is our goal at all. I know, personally, that's not my goal. When you talk about-- you're talking about two different things. One is acceptance, and one is tolerance. That's really what we're looking for. Asking for tolerance isn't really asking for a lot. It's just asking that you be able to say, you know, I don't endorse this. I don't agree with it. But I tolerate it. Certainly, acceptance would be great. But tolerance is really all that we're looking for.
不。我不认为那是我们的目标。我知道，就我个人而言，那不是我的目标。当你谈论……你在谈论两件不同的事情。一个是接受，一个是宽容。这确实是我们想要的。要求宽容其实并不是要求很多。它只是要求你能够说：你知道，我不支持这个。我不同意这一点。但我宽容它。当然，接受会很棒。但宽容确实是我们所追求的一切。
OK. I think I'm tolerant. I'm not going to agree with your lifestyle. And we're in some sense in a battle, it seems to be. That's probably what it is going to be for a while. And one of us is going to prevail, and one of us is not. And in the meantime, I don't want bad things happen to you. I don't want people to be mean, or physically harm you, or anything like that. I don't want the government harassing you. I hope this is not harassing. We disagree.
好的。我想我是宽容的。我不会同意你们的生活方式。而且我们似乎在某种意义上处于一场战斗中。看来还会持续一段时间。我们中会有一方获胜，另一方不会。在此期间，我不希望坏事发生在你们身上。我不希望人们表现卑劣，或身体上伤害你们，或类似的事情。我不希望政府骚扰你们。希望这不算骚扰。我们意见不同。
I don't think it's harassing at all.
我认为这根本不算骚扰。
We have an understanding of I know where you stand, and where you're feeling, and you know mine.
我们达成了一种理解：我知道你的立场和感受，你也知道我的。
They talked about gay marriage. Patrick ticked off a list of problems that gay couples face right now because they can't marry. Visitation in hospitals when a partner is sick, inheriting property when a partner dies. Even if there's a will, family members can contest it in court, he says. Steven said he'd never heard about that one.
他们谈到了同性婚姻。帕特里克列举了同性伴侣目前因为不能结婚而面临的一系列问题。当伴侣生病时的医院探视，当伴侣去世时的财产继承。他说，即使有遗嘱，家庭成员也可以在法庭上提出异议。史蒂文说他从没听说过那个。
Steven said his main problem with letting gays marry-- or have civil unions in some states-- is that it's hard to imagine that it would just be confined to a few states. Surely, he said, some liberal judge would make all the states recognize the marriages. And from his point of view, it's just the next thing in a slippery slope. Christians lost the right to pray in schools, there's Roe versus Wade, then no-fault divorce. This is just one more thing that he's teaching his kids is wrong, that society says is OK.
史蒂文说，他对于允许同性恋者结婚（或在某些州进行民事结合）的主要问题是，很难想象这会仅仅局限于几个州。他说，肯定会有某个自由派法官会让所有州承认这种婚姻。从他的角度来看，这只是“滑坡效应”中的下一件事。基督徒失去了在学校祈祷的权利，出现了《罗诉韦德案》，然后是无过错离婚。这只是他在教导孩子们这是错误、而社会却说这是没问题的又一件事。
The fact that Patrick's religious, goes to church, his six-year-old son goes to a religious school, all means something to Steven.
帕特里克是有宗教信仰的，去教堂，他六岁的儿子上宗教学校，这一切对史蒂文来说都有意义。
I want him to be a good father. I want to be a good father. Our quote "society" as a whole, I think, probably in a lot of ways, would be better off, if people was interested in their children, probably, as Patrick is-- is it a son, is that what you said?
我希望他能成为一个好父亲。我想成为一个好父亲。我认为我们整个“社会”，可能在很多方面会更好，如果人们像帕特里克一样关心他们的孩子……是儿子，那是你说的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. I think it's fine that you're involved in a church there and things, whatever. I do wonder what the church-- and how the church, gets around the clear teaching in scripture against homosexuality.
是的。我认为你参与那里的教会以及其他事情很好，不管怎样。我确实想知道教会……以及教会如何绕过圣经中对同性恋明确的教导。
Here's what I have trouble with. You would never-- well, I'm not going to put words in your mouth. But if someone came to your church and was divorced, you would never tell that person, you are committing adultery. That's what Jesus said in the Bible. He said that if you divorce and remarry, you're committing adultery with that person.
这是我有麻烦的地方。你永远不会……嗯，我不会替你说话。但如果有人来你的教堂，而且是离婚的，你永远不会告诉那个人：你正在通奸。那是圣经中耶稣所说的。他说如果离婚再婚，你就是在那个人身上犯了通奸罪。
I agree.
我同意。
Your church, I'll bet, doesn't tell people that are divorced that. From the pulpit, look over at the divorced people that are sitting there, that have remarried, and say, every time you sleep with your new husband, you're committing adultery. And so, what you've done, and what you're able to do, probably, and what your church does, is you cherry-pick things from the Bible that are going to be something that you hold out as a principle. And the other stuff you conveniently leave in there, and close it, and put it out of your mind. And for whatever reason, homosexuality is one of those things that has been cherry-picked out, and has been, for whatever reason, given this different status.
我敢打赌，你的教堂不会那样告诉离婚的人。不会从讲坛上看着坐在那里、已经再婚的离婚者说：你们每次和新丈夫睡觉，你们就是在通奸。所以，你已经做的、很可能能够做到的、以及你的教堂所做的，是你从圣经中“樱桃采摘”了一些东西，并将其作为一个原则保持。而其他东西你方便地留在那儿，合上它，不去想它。而无论出于什么原因，同性恋就是被樱桃采摘出来的那件事，并且无论出于什么原因，被赋予了这种不同的地位。
I think you make an excellent point. And I think the way you put it, about the cherry-picking, is correct. But even with the hypocrisy, that I admit is there, that doesn't get around with what scripture says.
我认为你提出了一个极好的观点。我认为你关于樱桃采摘的说法是正确的。但即使有伪善，我也承认那里有伪善，那并不能绕过经文所说的。
Well, we talked about tolerance. And I think that tolerance can go both ways, because I can tolerate what I see as the hypocrisy in a lot of churches, if you can tolerate that there are people that have a different view of what God's message is, or what the scripture means, or what the application is to our individual lives. Understand that we've got to tolerate those views and try to focus on things we do agree on. Because there's a lot.
嗯，我们谈到了宽容。我认为宽容可以双向进行，因为我可以宽容我所看到的许多教堂里的虚伪，如果你能宽容有这样的人，他们对上帝的信息、经文的含义或对我们个人生活的应用有不同的看法。要理解我们必须宽容那些观点，并尝试关注我们确实同意的事情。因为有很多。
I agree. I think there is a lot. But know and understand this, and getting back just within the Republican Party, we're going to continue to have this struggle, disagreement, on the platform.
我同意。我认为有很多。但要知晓并理解这一点，回到共和党内部，我们仍将继续在这场斗争中，在纲领上存在分歧。
If those platform revisions change, would you leave the party?
如果那些纲领修改了，你会离开这个党吗？
Well, no, I don't think I'd be OK. And that's when I would come to the point of, will I continue to be a Republican? What am I going to do? There's going to be a struggle. There's going to be a conflict. One of us will be OK, or happy, and one of us won't. It is my thought-- belief, or whatever-- I think over time, even though I may disagree with it, I think Patrick ultimately is going to get his wish. I hope that doesn't happen, but I-- being a realist-- I think that will happen whether [INAUDIBLE] or not. That's what I believe. Perhaps in the future-- it may be in 20 or 25 years-- it's just no big deal. It's not a forefront issue. I don't know.
嗯，不，我认为我不行。那时我会走到那一步：我还会继续做共和党人吗？我要做什么？将会有斗争。将会有冲突。我们中会有一个人没问题或高兴，而另一个人不会。我的想法……信仰，不管怎样……我认为随着时间推移，尽管我可能不同意，但我认为帕特里克最终会实现他的愿望。我希望那不会发生，但我……作为一个现实主义者……我认为那无论如何都会发生。这就是我相信的。也许在未来……可能是在20或25年后……这就没什么大不了的了。这不是一个前沿议题。我不知道。
That's what I'm working for.
那正是为了之奋斗的目标。
Steven said that if the Republican Party ever became pro-choice, he'd definitely have to leave. On gay issues, he'll wait and see how he feels. Like he says, what's probably going to happen is, either Patrick's going to be unhappy with the party's position-- and struggling from within to change it-- or Steven will.
史蒂文说，如果共和党变成支持堕胎选择权，他肯定得离开。在同性恋议题上，他会等等看自己的感觉。正如他所说，很可能会发生的是，要么帕特里克对党的立场不满意（并在内部斗争以改变它），要么史蒂文会不满意。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollack. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Amy O'Leary.
嗯，我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我本人制作，戴安·库克、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格和丽莎·波拉克参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和艾米·奥利里提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
You know, you can download audio of our show at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, best-selling books, even The New York Times , all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道，你可以从audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们的节目音频，他们那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至是《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。 《这美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who swears whenever we try to put him on the show--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他每当我们试图让他上节目时都会咒骂——
You and your left-wing liberal friends, trying to corner me, just like Michael Moore? Trying to ambush me?
你和你的左翼自由派朋友，像迈克尔·摩尔一样试图围堵我？试图伏击我？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《这美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。